where would trees once existed all over
Westeros that is until the Andals
arrived and took the southern lands from
the first mint we know that the children
of the forest claimed the trees were
linked to their gods and we know that
the first men later adopted these
so-called gods weirwood trees are unlike
any other tree found in Westeros if
untouched aware which we will live
forever though their bark is white
their SAP is a deep breath that
curiously resembles blood in a dance
with dragons when bran finally
encounters the true form of the
three-eyed crow beneath the ancient
weirwood tree he finds not only blood
Raven and the children of the forest but
dead things as well there are bones
bones of men bones of children bones of
giants bones of animals all scattered
before the grain sirrah throne why the
strange display is there perhaps an
ominous explanation it is believed that
the first men of Westeros thousands of
years ago sometimes replace the bodies
of the condemned at the base of where
woods and even at times place the
entrails and limbs within the branches
this custom is largely unexplained even
till this day however the stone born of
sky ghosts are rumored to still keep
this practice on the Iron Islands there
are stories of yeegh the demon tree
according to the legend gig was a great
tree with pale wood jig fed on human
flesh and was cut down by the grey King
and made into the world's first long
ship we don't know whether or not the
legend of gig refers to a weirwood tree
but the fact that it has pale wood seems
to be a pretty big hit the story of gig
is well known in the Iron Islands in a
dance with dragons during Stannis's
snowstorm Oscar Greyjoy seems very
distrusting and fearful of the strange
northern trees she even knows how much
the SAP looks like blood it's only SAP
she told herself the red sap that flows
inside these ware woods but her eyes
were unconvinced seeing was believing
and what they saw was frozen blood Davos
29 a dance with dragons if he is
described as a weirwood tree on the Iron
Islands and it would make sense that
assuming someone who grew up on Pyke
would be suspicious of wear which leads
to some extent having heard the legend
of Jaeger entirely
it is likely that the legend of Yaga
originated from outsiders discovering
weirwood trees surrounded by human bones
over time the tale shifted from the
strange to the unnatural and these
custom of the first men became the tales
of the pale demon jury but this begs the
question why does such a strange custom
exist in the first place in the prologue
of a Dance with Dragons varamyr six
skins collapses bleeding before a
weirwood tree very mere can feel the
heart tree watching him and his mind
drift to the horrible things that he's
done in his life when varamyr finally
dies for an instant he is part of the
weirwood he sees himself twitching and
dying in the snow he feels as though he
is one with the forest one with nature a
horned owl flew silently between his
trees hunting a hare Vera Muir was
inside the owl inside the hair inside
the trees deep below the frozen ground
earthworms barrowed blindly in the dark
and he was them all as well I am the
wood and everything that's in it he
thought exalting the prologue a dance
with dragons so just for a moment as he
lays dying bleeding into the weirwood
bear Amir becomes a part of the forest
he experiences in that instance of
oneness with nature like nothing he had
ever felt before it only ends when he
chooses to inhabit the body of his wolf
it seems as though about allowing
himself to die alongside the tree he
unknowingly offered his soul to the
woods because of his power as a
skin-changer he was able to live a
second life through his wolf instead
when brand asked one of the children of
the forest about the rest of their kind
she responds that they were gone down
into the earth into the stones and into
the trees this suggests that when the
children died they experience the same
oneness with the forest and nature that
varamyr did just for that instant in
other words they experienced an
afterlife the idea of an afterlife would
seem to contradict the show's insistence
that there is only darkness after death
but does it truly there is no indication
that such an afterlife exists for those
who died beyond the reach of weirwood
trees if the weirwood trees can provide
a kind of afterlife for someone who dies
near one then the bones at the base of
the trees start to make more sense we
have no evidence that where what trees
are linked to gods in any real way we
know that the weirwood store memories
and that green seers can watch through
them
the idea that one can exist after death
was likely highly appealing to the first
men who if the TV show is correct live
in a world where there is nothing after
death we don't know why the first men
agreed to adopt the so-called gods of
the children of the forest we know that
the pact stated that no more weirwood
trees were to be cut down but that says
nothing about the first men taking the
nameless gods for themselves what if the
first men were deceived the old gods
aren't real the religion of the old gods
is one that the children intentionally
lead mankind into we know that much of
the power of the children of the forest
is linked to the weirwood trees what
better way to ensure the protection of
their power source then to convince
mankind to literally worship them and
the purpose of the bones it does seem as
though dying before our weirwood tree
does grant some kind of afterlife but
that's not all it does when Vera Mir
bled into the grounds and his blood
soaked into the we're woods roots his
mind became a part of the weirwood tree
as well if Vera Mir had not Ward into
his wolf would he have remained a part
of this oneness forever if so then the
implications could be huge because those
who have died before the weirwood tree
must still exist in some form within the
collective of where woods could this
mean that one day bran may have access
to them through them perhaps he could
learn the secrets that the children of
the forest and blood Raven are keeping
from him in any case it is known that
during the war between the first men and
the children the first men feared the
weirwood so they cut them down on sight
wherever they came across them the best
way for the children to protect their
source of power was to convince the
first men that these trees were God
whatever magic the where woods possess
it's a part of the natural world of the
Song of Ice and Fire this was a magic
harnessed by the children and used to
manipulate mankind it seems as though
the pact between men and children never
truly solved anything because the war
never actually ended thank you guys for
watching make sure you would like and
subscribe for more ideas of Ice and Fire